hey guys I'm a lot of welcome to my
Channel today I'm playing more of alien
isolation it's been a while since the
last time I played it but oh I just
thought like plan it again so I thought
that I would and okay this is where I
died exactly last time so this is right
where we left off so Oh bria better luck
this time and all right reactivate
Samuels communication hey so basically
there are lots of synthetics and not
that many save points I missed one
before but i did find at this time so um
chances are better this time around um
alright so I'm still trying to get in
contact with my ship I kind of I
remember how to play this I guess I
should you should just be in this room
um because yeah some of the some of the
controls o auld this thingy yes hello
friend remove immediately huh okay that
and that up that and then
damn it emergency override in a good way
okay so we'll do this one now
what
how do I 2930 what I have to get that
same as bottom yeah okay number three
please no all right huh this doesn't
really make sense okay what's going on
you're alive it's rippling Taylor
swiftly we were getting worried we made
it where are you we're the transit
station now it's wife I met her I
medical okay Samuels listen to me it's
not safe here seek sins got misplaced
loctite their goddamn androids are
killing people that's impossible it's
contrary to primary synthetic program
I've seen it Samuel i guess nobody about
synthetics and there's something else
here a creature it's big and it's lethal
Ripley slow down creature it's a life
for you I don't tight some kind of alien
organism it's extremely dangerous you
and Tanner very good voice acting she
was injured by debris during the
crossing how bad I can't move I need
medical supplies we need to treat and
patterns the radio is broken I can't
contact the owner we're on our own [ __ ]
okay I'll come to you keep your eyes
open Oh Pentagon dekomia yeah
where to friend back that way ah oh god
no no no no i'm totally gonna die here
on I there's someone behind me uh uh oh
dead end oh dear God oh oh oh oh doh so
we're very close game okay okay okay yes
it is so don't stop looking for me not
worth looking for really I'm super
average okay do we want to get out here
surely they can't get advanced can they
surely not eyes are so buggy
anyone for anyone anyone in front of me
here hello uh-huh this room seems to be
okay yeah okay
all right yeah okay let's keep going the
god for these vents man say vyas why is
this buggy answer on I don't understand
something something signals something
sci-fi sci-fi okay so there's probably
someone out here no no oh Jesus
this where it came from and it going the
right way don't think that door was
right it was the same thing there i miss
it again are you kidding me ah damn it
I'm just gonna get back you're ok i'm
not i don't think I'm swish to go
through that door no this is where I
came from ok no oh no on our owner on
our oh no no no no no no knock knock
knock knock hiding hiding hiding hiding
you coming you coming buddy are you just
walking around out there what are you
doing talk to me man ok it's not what
this one did I swear yet like if oh no
what are you doing what are you doing
are you approaching me or not you're
just standing that I wonder if it's see
me if I open the door I don't know
oh sees me I'm dead night I ain't
getting back out of here which way do I
go from here straightish yep oh oh oh
where are you where are you you're in
the room if Ronnie since wandered to the
immediate right oh Jesus how am I not
seen him yet it was so close Oh God
are they coming are you do coming it's
three what I thought the hell is
happening here it's so hard for me to
figure out where they are he isn't
moving but he's pretty damn close right
ah he's got to be so close right now
it's like my controllers vibrating so
odd can you just yet do that yeah walk
away okay that's good that's good yes oh
I don't feel comfortable doing this at
all but something something you're
greater good something something bravery
and such okay about now I have to go
through that why does there he say
points around not have to go all right
back through here oh Jesus okay so maybe
that guy who's coming up isn't a fully
different rooms is obviously to honor I
don't know if you just saw me I don't
think you did oh my god is your standing
that oh my god yep he's just he's just
gonna stand there and he's gonna walk
away it's gonna be fine gonna be fine
there's synthetic life-forms obviously
don't have the best eyesight like I'm
looking right at you mate right here
okay just walked away okay is he gone
yeah yeah he's gone okay
okay yes with line on that count you
know this want to write in here oh no no
no no no stop vibrating please no stop
stop that stop making me very
uncomfortable stop it stop vibrating oh
ok so I think the one in here stays on
the outside of the room if I just keep
walking through I should be fine no no
no no ya go away no Jesus Christ is
stressful ok ok ok ok it's not a me it's
not near me I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine
fine fine totally fine made it ok
are you still going off like crazy stop
it just dress mad wonderful the guy does
go through there but uh nothing
happening oh jesus oh jesus oh no okay
it should be one kind from me where was
that guy going nowhere [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] he is still there okay oh
man oh man oh man look at it going off
standing right here is problematic
because I'm not going to know when he is
passed by rosie was around that side no
he comes back over here and then goes
back around again so okay she's coming
this way right now wide right here no
Sammy sure right next me right now don't
look in here did not look in here so you
should be looking at the way right yeah
yeah yeah and under the desk going for
the desk oh okay so I'm gonna have to
wait for him to move away and is one
over the other side as well maybe I
could just walk past in me know well
it's good that I didn't okay yeah fiddle
with that computer or something
what are you doing you stop there oh
there's another one up there damn okay
maybe maybe I should wait for him 200
two of them surely they would have no
reason to look on her desk there right
what a synthetics went with desks
nothing Jesus okay he's right right here
ah we're gonna wait for this guy to walk
over to this computer and stop again
because you know apparently again since
that except terrible eyesight can't see
things that are plainly in front of them
where's the other one I don't know where
he is I don't know where he is it seems
like there's anyone here see huge risk
it's a massive giant breaking the risk
I'm taking right now oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no god I want to run I'm gonna
run so bad I can't can't run please
nobody noticed me don't notice me no I'm
just along here okay I think he'll be
all right okay grab this
and then yes hello ah thank you okay so
where to from here back to the place
that I was yes yes I desperately want to
override my sight of daughter thank you
so much oh ok no that's all right sir I
feel like going back to where I was a
bad idea cuz EPPA to its back here is
this the right way you genuinely want me
to go this way yep ok let's do it
I thought I saw something that was
really just the smoke from that vent ah
they're probably gonna make me go
through about side part aren't they know
it no ok so i can go back through this
way yeah you don't want me to go in that
room it seems like you probably do no
wow ok thank Christ for that let us go
back as you swear produc produc you it
is just occurred to me that the music is
getting a Leonie it really is isn't it
nothing but that Israeli and sounds like
you're probably gonna show up soon I
said what am I guard from you back
literally back the way that I came which
I know isn't good because whoa whoa whoa
that's alien right there right there oh
my god um oh I don't know what to do so
I have alien right above me right now
find me behind me right now in there
aliens nearby I don't know where the
synthetic is ah can you see me you just
saw me didn't you you just [ __ ] saw
me leg it leggett la no I shouldn't be
liking it when I landscape I oh this is
all just a whole lot of nasty hide yes
I'd okay okay all right
is that the synthetic or is it alien
both get here man events
there's a save point next to me I'm
gonna go for it get out
hello Oh sound of nothing just scared me
was that there wasn't barely even a
sound and I just freaked out yes
desperately thank you